by the way speaking of the grammys jd
said bruno was wearing pants that showed
off his bulge during his performance and
oh my gosh i saw i couldn't stop staring
at it
i was looking at everyone else's pants
to see if they had bulges too and
bruno was the only one that had this
bulge popping out i was like jesus good
for him
so when you look at a guy on stage
performing you look at his
that you look to see if he has a bulge
listen i don't
i don't know how my eyes ended up there
but they ended up there and once they
were there they couldn't leave
it was bouncing up and down i was like
jesus christ
do you have a bald jd isn't jd supposed
to be packing
yeah but at times excuse you robin
uh i'm not quite like bruno mars i don't
think but
uh you know it's fine it's all right how
big are you jd how many inches
i'm i think i'm like average like six
you know oh
wow nothing to brag about i mean i've i
haven't
i haven't measured since high school so
yes you have stop it no i haven't i've
never had a rule you think you grew
since high school
no no no no i don't i don't think it
start i you know i don't think it uh i
think it's where it stopped
so how many inches were you when you
measured in high school
it was like six it was around six was it
like six or six
listen you know i don't remember exactly
where the tip
and the thing in a ruler matched up but
it was around
six i know that i know when i don't let
him build your house
because he's not exactly i'm not
building houses
no so you had a ruler and where did you
put it like at the base or do you
measure from your boat
at the base yeah right so you laid it on
the
on the ruler uh no i put it side by side
all right okay oh you didn't put it
underneath you see i put it underneath
my pound
i don't want to miss it from the base of
the balls no it was like you know
uh how do i like this is my opinion
like this is my penis and then i put a
ruler
up against it you know side by side and
that was it
and you say you measured six inches was
it a little under or a little over
uh it might it might have been a little
uh over
oh okay uh but yeah it wasn't well not
by much
who knows what have you measured i'm
gonna have to measure them when we get
back to work
ronnie you'll uh you'll hold jd down and
i'll measure them
gonna be like high school exactly
you